all right what's up guys i'm master here
joined alongside trevor ziegris from the
anaheim ducks it's been a crazy week for
you i want to get down to the beginning
right you starting as a hockey player
have you always been kind of that
creative player like were there any guys
in the league that you were looking up
to pavel datsuk any guys like that yeah
i mean i was a big caner fan okay i love
younger i love i love the way he played
um obviously datsu crosby i think all
those guys
um i mean i think i just just in general
i think i was just a hockey fan so i
loved watching everybody
but i definitely say kaner was probably
my favorite player growing up and
all the crazy passes and spin moves that
he did i mean i love trying that in the
driveway or
minor hockey or at prep school and all
that good stuff so i want to talk about
the play that happened with you and
sonny milano obviously you took the
hockey world by storm walk me through
that play step by step so you're sitting
behind the net milano calls out for the
michigan what's going through your head
yeah well i mean at first i tried it
kind of just tried to settle the puck
down and see if anybody would kind of
chase me behind the net and once my guy
on i guess it was the right side for me
uh kind of just decided to chill out on
the post um obviously sonny was calling
for the michigan and um i knew i
couldn't couldn't do the actual michigan
because that guy was kind of chilling on
the post
so i just flipped it over to that and um
he was ready for it and he made a great
play so i mean i feel like most of the
credit should be going to him because
without sunny i mean that's just a it's
just a it's a it's a no play really and
um for him to kind of put it in that top
corner uh was was definitely pretty
special on his end so this is not
something that you guys had like worked
on practice the night before the flip
play obviously you're working on that
michigan and crossing it all day but the
flip play was not something you drew up
right
no we've never even talked about that
before that's why
that's why i was pretty shocked when it
went in i didn't really know what
happened because the guy kind of pushed
me after i flipped it over the net so i
didn't really see it so i was kind of
just in shock like did we really just do
that dude that's unreal i think that
makes the play even better do you have a
target on your back when you're behind
the net like do you feel like the
opponents kind of know that these crazy
things are coming do you feel like they
want to maybe hit you harder because of
that or anything
uh i don't know but it was the next game
we were in columbus and we played
columbus and i got behind the net in the
first period and i got two guys kind of
just came right on me and
the boards so i was like maybe that's
maybe that's the end of my run behind
the net so let's talk about some of your
other plays too right you try to go
between your legs didn't go in you go
back to the bench you're a little bummed
out uh are your your teammates a little
rattled by that or they want you to go
with a simple backhand like what's that
like uh no they they think it's awesome
for the most part nobody really kind of
gets on me for doing that stuff i don't
know like a lot of people like they love
to comment or chime in and say like
you gotta just go backhand there but
like to me like i just don't understand
like what's the difference between like
flipping a backhand versus like flipping
a forehand and um i think honestly i
looked at it a couple times and i think
it was just a a great save by uh i think
it was robin leonard on vegas
he read it great and he kind of stayed
with me but i thought i guess i had
enough speed that um he kind of be
following the puck and it would kind of
just sneak in i guess on the far side
but
he made a great save you're the
definition of changing the game right
people have to change the way that they
play and you're making them do that and
speaking of changing the game we
couldn't have this talk without bringing
this up john tortorella his comments on
you i'm sure you saw them what are your
thoughts on what he had to say
yeah i mean i thought it was uh
definitely a little uh out of the
ordinary um because where i always like
torts man like growing up i was a big
ranger fan obviously he coached the
rangers um so i was always a big
tortorella fan i love kind of that he
was a little bit outspoken and had his
own opinion um and sonny sonny played
for him for five years and sunny had
nothing but great things to say about
him
so i guess for him to kind of
take that goal i don't know if he took
it personal or what not
but it was definitely
definitely a little out of the ordinary
for sure and um i guess like you said i
don't know changing the game man like i
saw so many so many awesome videos of
little kids trying it or um i guess
whether it was college kids or whatnot
so i mean to me personally i took a lot
of pride in i guess maybe trying to
inspire somebody to pick up a hockey
stick um but i guess if he wanted to
take it as it was bad for the game i
guess that's just his opinion
yeah i can really respect that answer i
don't think torts meant any you know ill
intent by that he's just old school you
know dump the puck low shoot low for
rebounds that's that's the kind of guy
he is but yeah i could say personally i
walked into my rink for a beer league
game this week no joke i saw the guys
flipping the puck with the net going for
your play so you're inspiring the youth
around the country man i appreciate
everything you're doing changing the
game of hockey and that we appreciate
you hopping on this interview
thanks nash right i picked up some stuff
watching you on youtube bro
oh no you did not yeah i saw you i saw
your roller hockey highlights bro that's
where my uh where some of the eggs comes
from you've got to be kidding me i
posted that and i thought i was just
kind of making a joke i didn't know you
actually watched the videos
of course man dude i appreciate the love
thank you so much and uh best of luck
going forward this year man thanks man
appreciate it